ah yes the one-man army if you ever need
to show up how strong one of your
characters is this is the way to go
there aren't many things more satisfying
than seeing a lone character showing off
how badass they are by demonstrating
their strength in a battle with a
numbers handicap on that note let's take
a look at the top ten of one-man-army
moments in anime now real quick I want
to give a shout out to the sponsor of
this video
pure VP M if you didn't know pure vpns
of fast and reliable service that
secures your connection on all your
devices with easy to use apps across all
major platforms article 13 as mature
people know we'll put a lot of
restrictions to content creators inside
the EU so having a VPN connection will
help you with unblocking all the
exciting content which may otherwise be
blocked in your region or country be
sure to check out the link in my
description to get purevpn
as 74 percent off the normal price and
get connected
sign things off we have Fabiola fighting
the Colombian cartel the Colombian
cartels probably one of the most feared
organizations around however in one
memorable episode of Black Lagoon
it seems that its members entered the
wrong neighborhood they thought that
they can have their way in a bar with a
seemingly hapless maid but unfortunately
for them the maid they decided to mess
with is none other than Fabiola and
she's armed to the core utilizing the
environment to its maximum potential she
goes on a rampage dancing around the
battlefield as nimbly as she can she
finishes her work in no time and leaves
the bar in ruins here's a lesson for you
all don't judge someone by their
appearance chances are the more innocent
they look the more likely they can kick
your ass and make a show of it
[Applause]
[Music]
at number nine is God or fighting the
Yakuza Gatos debut appearance in
parasites nothing short of impressive
encountering the Yakuza he slaughters
members of the notorious gang with his
bare hands
he doesn't even break a sweat in
finishing the battle I mean actually
it's not a battle at all it's a
bloodbath once so easily delivered by
this one-man wrecking crew or should I
say five parasite wrecking crew where's
yeah he claims to be only testing his
limitations all of this is only a
preview of what's to come as the
military will realize in the climax of
the series
Shinichi and McGee have their work cut
out for them if they hope to defeat this
force of nature known as gamma Takaoka
nuna
Chiqui takes on Apartments on piece in
our number eight moment this is probably
one of the fans favorite fight in garden
of sinners and for good reason
she kiri okie becoming a graceful and
deadly engine of destruction for just a
minute and a half is a sight to see one
by one she dispatches the zombies
without much effort at all even when the
odds start to inevitably turn against
her due to the numbers disadvantage she
still prevails thanks to her quick wit
in the end as she leaves behind a trail
of corpses in her wake and she does this
all in a kimono with a knife let that
sink in for a moment
[Music]
[Music]
we have Afro Samurai slicing his way to
number seven on this list want any more
proof that your main character is one
huge badass let the opening battle in
Afro Samurai show you the way completely
surrounded by enemies Afro Samurai shows
no fear and simply stares down at the
enemy in front of him to him everything
is but cannon fodder bullets kanai's and
hordes of enemies charging at him pose
no threat as he dispatches multiple
opponents in a single slash it's a
massacre like no other courtesy of our
protagonist and he's just getting
started nothing personal just another
day in the life of the one who vows
revenge and seeks to be the strongest in
the world six on the list we have Goro
taking on the heroes in one punch man
making his intentions of seeking strong
fighters known garu taunts the heroes
into taking him on all at once and we
know how that goes Goro 'no only faces
off in this fight against several top a
ranked heroes like chained and toed gun
gun shooter Wildhorn and death catholic
but also s ranked heroes like jane
austen bang janice who arrived on the
scene thanks to a call for backup
quickly proves he's a difficult adverse
with his new upgrades soon we see bang
and his brother bomb make a grand
entrance the two master martial artists
prepare to end his life but Garo in his
anger and despair commences a
counterattack with tank top masters tank
top blow unfortunately the fight ends
abruptly due to phoenix man and elder
centipede the heroes better be prepared
for the return of the monster
coming in at number five we take a look
at shimazaki highlight in mob psycho
second season having done his job in
defeating terror
shimazaki continues to go on a tear in
his debut appearance in the series in a
show of arrogance shimazaki provokes a
fight out of the former scars it ends
just as well as you'd expect with
shimazaki coming out on top
despite the numbers disadvantage now
just when you think shimazaki shows
weakness in his subsequent fights he
simply reestablishes that he's a league
above the rest this was easily one of
the best animated sequences of the
entire series it was really exciting to
see as everyone pitches in to help to
defeat this monster of an opponent
[Music]
fourth on the list is guts battling a
hundred soldiers in berserk it's no
secret that guts is one hardcore
swordsman with no need for magic or any
kind of anime stock powers guts is just
out there to show that he's just that
strong of course one of his key
performances comes in the form of taking
on an army by himself in Golden Age
we're not talking about a dozen or so
enemies here we are talking about a
hundred soldiers 100 against one without
any super powers whatsoever guts shows
off his sheer strength in the display of
raw power I doubt anyone can be as
badass as that no wonder he has the
nickname a hundred man Slayer to his
credit
sliding off our top three is Luo Liang
versus the bandits in sword of the
stranger it seems these moments make
their home at the beginning of stories
in another one-man-army moment that
happens at the start of a story luo
liang takes on bandits that set up an
ambush on the ming dynasty warriors
let's just say that like a lot of the
moments we've already gone through the
fights less of a fight but more of a
massacre in this case what makes this
moment extra special is the overall
ambiance the pumping music sleek
animation and the panning shots that
follow the action or help feel the
intensity to make this one awesome
opening act to a movie right off the bat
new orlean gets established as one of
the most fearsome characters in this
movie in one hell of a performance
Sam Mendes Yuri watashi o Cristero no
erotica in a yoga
at number 2 we have oats or o vs.
everyone yes you heard that right vs.
everyone in this fight good sorrow
demonstrates why he deserves to be known
as the most overpowered swordsman in the
world of anime it looks like he's not
even trying in this fight and he's more
than a match for the parade of badasses
all coming to get him
special mention to shinpachi but I would
say that everyone gets his moment of
glory in this pandemonium of a final
fight however no one comes out of it
looking better than good sorrow himself
whose immortality doesn't even seem to
matter in this battle in the end I think
that this fight is so good that it can
actually be interchanged with the number
one fight on the list which is slightly
edge seeing at zero go dynasty Warriors
on his foes okay with the story hermosa
rare
[Music]
what would make the number one
one-man-army moments on the list none
other than mother are fighting the
shinobi alliance this is a final villain
making a statement you'd think that
simply being restored by the arrow
Tensei would have robbed this legendary
ninja of his renowned power wrong the
entire fourth division is no match for
his skills intelligence and combat
tactics of the revived legend it's a
spectacle that has to be seen to be
believed
and I think this appearance perfectly
hypes the audience for what's to come
now that the big badass has lived up to
the hype
what sort of powers do Naruto and
friends have to pull out for this top
guy
spoiler alert nothing virtually nothing
could stop Madara at full strength all
in all it's an impressive show of
strength that's merely a sneak peek of
what he's capable of once everything's
said and done Martha is a far far
stronger than what he showed here it'd
take nothing short of pure divine
intervention to even have a hope of
going even with this legendary ninja
so that's going to do it for this video
I hope that the ten moments listed above
helped you satisfy your need to sit back
and watch one guy take care of business
if you have any other suggestions for
future lists or more one-man-army
moments please take the time to comment
and let us hear from you until next time
if you enjoyed the video hit that like a
notification bill button so that you
never miss videos like these and also
don't forget to check out our sponsor
purevpn the links in the description
I'll see you next time on beanie tube
[Music]
you
[Music]